[Applauso]
[Musica]
secondo voi è nato prima l'uovo o la
gallina
a detta di Borghese di Calvino
sembrerebbe l'uovo l'uovo cosmico per
Calvino l'inizio fu tutto in un punto
come recita il titolo di un suo breve
racconto e quel punto per Borges si
chiama Aleph come la prima lettera
dell'alfabeto ebraico che indica anche
il numero primordiale il numero che
contiene tutti gli altri numeri in quel
punto per Borges si trovano senza
confondersi tutti i luoghi della terra
visti da tutti gli angoli
quello che vi propongo questa sera è un
viaggio dalle origini del mondo
all'economia circolare attraverso cinque
parole chiave che useremo come appoggio
per spostarci da un punto all'altro le
cinque parole sono caos vuoto 0 ordine
economia circolare bene partiamo
all'inizio per primo venne a essere il
caos e da esso tutto tre origine
racconta Esiodo nella sua Teogonia
quindi è l'origine di tutto c'è il caos
Ecco la nostra prima parola chiave
Ma cosa intendiamo per caos primordiale
generalmente traduciamo questa parola
greca come disordine indifferenziato da
cui a un certo punto si origina Il cosmo
il mondo ordinato ma è corretta questa
lettura la vita è un passaggio da uno
stato di disordine a uno stato di ordine
forse è giunto il tempo di abbandonare
questo pregiudizio per farlo ci facciamo
aiutare dal Significato etimologico
della parola caos che ha così stretta
assonanza con il verbo greco Caino Che
significa spalancarsi o con la parola
greca kasma che significa voragine
abisso Ed è proprio questa l'immagine
con cui apre il racconto della creazione
nella Bibbia le tenebre erano sopra
l'abisso quindi all'origine per primo
venne a essere il caos la voragine
nell'abisso il vuoto Ecco la nostra
seconda parola chiave vuoto gli studi di
astrofisica ci dicono che non esiste un
sistema più rigidamente ordinato
regolato e simmetrico del vuoto
quindi all'inizio per primo venne a
essere il caos la voragine e l'abisso il
vuoto e cioè un sistema perfettamente
ordinato e regolato
ma a un certo punto in qualche modo
questo vuoto perfetto è regolato si
inceppa qualcosa all'improvviso irrompe
e in quel momento L'ordine si frantuma
in un istante la piccola fluttuazione
quantistica comincia a gonfiarsi a
dismisura che l'universo intero provenga
dal vuoto o per meglio dire che sia
ancora oggi tuttora un sistema vuoto che
nel tempo ha subito una metamorfosi
sembra essere l'ipotesi più convincente
della Moderna cosmologia dice Guido
Tonelli nel suo libro Genesi il racconto
delle origini l'energia totale
dell'universo Infatti è nulla come
quella di un sistema vuoto e questo ha
molto in comune con lo zero la nostra
terza parola chiave
furono gli indiani a conferire al
concetto di zero vuoto le proprietà di
numero ispirandosi al sistema
posizionale dei babilonesi Ma se per gli
indiani e poi per gli arabi il concetto
di zero vuoto era fondamentale per i
greci era terribile perché sfida la
logica
moltiplicare Infatti un qualsiasi altro
numero per Zero significa condannarlo La
nullità e non va meglio se Dividiamo per
Zero produciamo un assurdo logico
l'infinito e per i greci per i quali
l'ideale di perfezione costituito da una
sfera sempre uguale a se stessa nello
spazio nel tempo ma soprattutto finita
il concetto di zero vuoto equivale a una
bestemmia come può il vuoto contenere
l'infinito
e su questo paradosso la nostra civiltà
occidentale sembra essere andata in tilt
da una parte Infatti ha costruito quasi
un tabù sullo zero inteso come vuoto
horror vacui paura del vuoto per cui
siamo costretti a riempirci di cose a
riempire il tempo e riempire ogni spazio
perché ben vedere la paura del vuoto
evoca la paura della morte il nostro
essere creature mortali e per
contrastare la paura della morte la
società occidentale ha costruito e si è
appoggiato sulla narrazione del di più e
meglio fino ad abbracciare il mito della
crescita infinita
Ma è possibile una crescita infinita su
questo nostro mondo finito per
rispondere ci facciamo aiutare dalle due
leggi della termodinamica la prima legge
dice in un sistema isolato un sistema
cioè che non scambia l'energia né
materia col mondo circostante Come il
nostro universo l'energia complessiva
rimane la stessa può passare da una
forma all'altra per esempio quando ci
sfreghiamo le mani l'energia cinetica si
trasforma in energia termica ma
complessivamente l'energia non cambia il
secondo principio aggiunge e precisa in
un sistema isolato l'energia termica
passa sempre da un corpo più caldo a un
corpo più freddo quindi non obbedienza
al primo principio l'energia complessiva
dell'universo si conserva pur passando
da una forma all'altra ma
in obbedienza al secondo principio il
suo potenziale per raggiungere e fare un
lavoro utile diminuisce inesorabilmente
E questa perdita di utilità si chiama
entropia da qui discendono due semplici
verità i sistemi naturali tendono
inevitabilmente al disordine la seconda
nei sistemi naturali non è possibile la
crescita infinita
l'organizzazione la straordinaria
complessità di ogni forma di vita
Infatti è ampiamente bilanciata dal
disordine che si crea nel progressivo
consumarsi del sole
ricapitolando gli esseri viventi sistemi
naturali tendono inevitabilmente al
disordine e per contrastare questa
tendenza se imposto l'ordine imperativo
della crescita infinita unico ordine
possibile Ed ecco la nostra quarta
parola chiave ordine ma forse giunto il
tempo anche in questo caso come per i
miti dell'origine di abbandonare il
pregiudizio dell'ordine
l'economia circolare potrebbe essere una
narrazione differente per contrastare e
sovvertire l'Ordine della crescita
infinita Patto di sfidare questo ordine
fin dalla radice uno studio nel 2017 ha
proposto 10 R
di strategie di economia circolare
proponendo anche un ordine ben definito
dalla R più virtuosa alla r dopo la
quale c'è la discarica ve le mostro
ripensare riparare riciclare
ricondizionare e riusare e recuperare e
ricottenere rifiutare riconvertire e
ridurre ora vi chiedo Secondo voi Qual è
la R che apre la lista la R più virtuosa
emerge di pensare e vi chiedo Qual è
quella che la chiude dopo la quale c'è
la discarica
convertire
riciclare diversità bene
la maggior parte delle persone a questa
domanda pone la parola rifiutare in
ultima posizione decima perché la lega
la parola rifiuto cosa di zero valore
Ebbene proprio questa parola scartata
diviene testata ad angolo e anche parola
di Scandalo perché proprio la R
rifiutare che apre la lista delle
strategie possibili Ma la apre non come
R1 Ma come r0 come l'aleph come il
numero primordiale che contiene tutti
gli altri numeri è una R generativa solo
se sappiamo dire di no solo se abbiamo
il coraggio di disobbedire il sistema
che ci propone l'unico ordine possibile
della crescita infinita possiamo mettere
in campo nuove ordini di valore e
mettere nel giusto ordine le R
dell'economia circolare
Ed eccoci Giunti all'ultima parola del
nostro viaggio economia circolare
economia circolare prima di essere una
questione tecnica economica e
scientifica una questione di postura da
quale punto di vista scelgo di guardare
il mondo la terra vista dalla terra è
pressoché piatta lineare e se cambio
punto di vista la terra vista
dall'universo sembra una piccola
navicella spaziale ha detto del 1968
l'economista Kenneth holding ed
esattamente come una piccola navicella
spaziale le risorse che sono al suo
interno sono date limitate E così pure i
rifiuti che noi andiamo a produrre
rimangono all'interno della nostra
navicella terra con tutto il loro carico
materico sulla nostra navicella terra
non è possibile una mentalità lineare
estrarre produrre consumare gettare è
necessario una mentalità circolare come
circolare la forma della nostra
navicella terra una cosa significa
torniamo le nostre R Innanzitutto come
abbiamo detto bisogna avere il coraggio
di rifiutare rifiutare la narrazione
dominante che ci impone l'unico ordine
possibile della crescita infini ta poi
ripensare di pensare nostro modo di
produrre di consumare ma anche di
rapportarci con gli oggetti dobbiamo per
forza possedere un bene per poterlo
utilizzare o possiamo per esempio
affittarlo noleggiarlo o condividerlo e
poi ridurre ridurre la produzione di
sprechi di rifiuti magari comprando
sfuso ma anche ridurre la produzione di
beni inutili e superflui ridurre
l'utilizzo di materia vergine e fossile
rifiutare ripensare e ridurre le nostre
Tre Erre metodo cui seguono le 5 r vita
le 5 strategie che permettono di
allungare la vita di un Bene
Innanzitutto riusando e quindi
valorizzando il mercato dell'usato ma
anche donando scambiando e poi
ricottenere questa parola non esiste in
italiano ma noi ci siamo presi licenza
poetica e l'abbiamo coniata apposta per
contrastare l'imperativo dell'usa egetta
così forte nel mondo degli imballaggi
per cui un bene che è nato per contenere
deve continuare a contenere ricontenere
appunto da una bottiglia Una coppetta
mestruale e poi riparare e per questa R
servono competenze antiche come
competenze nuove saper riparare un paio
di scarpe riparare un PC e ancora
ricondizionare e quindi sostituire parti
vecchie con parti nuove aggiornate in un
telefonino non una lavatrice e infine
riconvertire cioè dare un nuovo utilizzo
un bene non più funzionante per esempio
una vecchia camera d'aria di una
bicicletta che diventa una cintura
oppure quando lo scarto di una filiera
produttiva diventa input in un nuova
filiera pensiamo alle vinacce bucce e
semi d'uva che diventano input e risorse
per fare una crema per il viso e infine
le R trasformazioni quando in mano non
ho più un bene ma un rifiuto devo
recuperarne il valore materico
attraverso riciclo e solo in ultima
istanza recuperarne anche il valore
energetico attraverso il recupero
energetico
siamo partiti dalle origini e abbiamo
capito che non possiamo più riferirci al
nostro universo come al Cosmo mondo
ordinato contrapposto al caos mondo
disordinato a rigore dovremmo parlare di
caos cosmico dice Guido Tonelli possiamo
Allora dire che ci sono ordini e ordini
e disordini e disordini ci sono ordini
che mettono in risalto la bellezza della
diversità e ci sono ordini che
schiacciano l'essere un'unica sola
verità ci sono disordini Che evocano
paura ancestrali e ci sono disordini che
permettono stelle nuove di nascere così
l'economia circolare può essere una
dottrina per ribadire l'ordine della
crescita senza fine
Oppure può essere un invito al disordine
a guardare da un'altra prospettiva
perché come diceva il filosofo bisogna
avere il caos dentro di sé per partorire
una Stella danzante
[Musica]